welcome to this video one playing krupa
the M Cooper yeah who is that again
Charlie cop okay got a good score
against the sky two and a half out of
three okay playing the super solid
Queens gambit declined back to basics
yeah and I need to try that the latest
trend in the Queens gambit declined
exchange and some it's a fairly solid
line really am and only aniline that
only recently really got recognized as a
decent option for black it's quite
strange people took very long to
recognize that i actually had analyzed
this yes years ago and always thought
that black is kind of okay I mean not
not that it is brilliant but kind of
okay yeah this disposition is some is
nothing special in particular if he goes
b5 I can go see 5 this position is quite
okay the b5 porn is also a liability for
white of course d 5 is not great for
black but I have some some counter play
especially in mine appears endgames this
kind of structure can be very nice for
black as the King can come up to d6 and
c5 I know that sounds kind of far off
but i'll give me let's am I going on it
might happen okay let's go here
as sometimes not clear if you want to go
to e6 or 27 with that bishop yeah that's
interesting he might take only six it's
a bit 0 hat so somewhat unclear thing I
mean it's not clear to me that it's good
or not I came let's go here i have i
blundered 95 now or something no I
happened I've got a queen d 5 may be
back row rank is a bit weak that's
something that could be tricky have to
be a bit alert but I don't see a trick
here really naughty for no not really
there's no tricks
okay so let's just take them no use in
doing anything fancy okay um yeah what
now give me make sure that i'm not back
ranked mated like just six or something
okay I cannot sacrifice find it's got
Bishop everyone at the end and it's not
clear that i have anything in this
particular situation so i move the Queen
question is where maybe just here Luke
c8 bishop CA to staff no problem I want
to go to this seven anyway ya knowed i
mentioned the minor peas endgames this
this could easily happen in this
position if he gets a queen trade and in
mhm i can bring it to his seven I think
no no reason not to my king is quicker
in joining the action that's an
important important part of that to see
you want what does he want to do really
Quincy five or something that's no good
really 95 mmm I thought just Bishop see
aid didn't see any particular problem
with that
okay so Knight to d7 huh getting rid of
that night if I cheek with with the
night mm-hmm it's got night F for coming
No
I for quick wins seven or something nice
going there Jan I really have to just to
trade really sorry look I just really
only have to trade Queens and I'm okay
maybe 97 Quincy five or something okay
hmm I wanted to go h5 but it doesn't it
doesn't seem to work I cannot take his
snide their eyes bishop
if I go h5 he really has Bishop just six
that's no good but anyway if he I mean
you cannot take on age 70 I'm like we
need three or something some or Queenie
five that looks weird just looks wrong
okay but it's not really i'm not really
winning material in there if it takes
her I've Knight f6 now queen and I've
Queen a3 Queen g7 night of 6 wins apiece
okay so he couldn't take them means that
i will get the Queen's traded probably
with Quincy five
okay so the question is do I treat
myself or do I have an alternative I can
go be six if I trade myself I cannot
really attack as default porn
unfortunately they're not really okay
when I cannot cook into these six or
anything like that let's take it and go
from there Knight to f5 would be good
checking this but difficult too
difficult to get okay and fix some stuff
on dark squares if he allows it
I can go at four know himself that
Bishop move was pretty good time warning
ah interesting 94 or not tested and then
I move for can also try to go over here
I asked I Bishop e2 I what we're looking
I've been ignoring very simple moves
that's a bit bit annoying really chef
okay
and we will be 65 prob Alvin on time
actually position is probably not great
like my hands official her the night is
strapped down what a weird position it's
probably probably draw probably a draw
he goes like here here and gets it back
at said wrong oh yeah it was a bit i
mean i was i was really am glad to get
the Queen tradin which is I thought
after that only black can be better
because of my better King but maybe it's
just a draw that's very likely actually
thought maybe this gives me something
but he's just about right with f4 end
and that's that that equalizes something
that's very nothing nothing happening
check I tried a bit here and here maybe
have something better 93 is better yeah
i can actually yes i can go around here
and i have if i go here here I've Bishop
to e6 as well Oh
tricky let me I want to want to check if
I had some some early issue here on it
it was okay yeah this structure in
general is not that bad for black it's
kind of a kind of okay check the reason
is that blacks pieces are pretty sound
yeah our pretty well placed all those is
kind of harmonious and why doesn't have
a clear thing to attack d 5 is not
particularly weak I think this is about
equal maybe maybe why does a slight
advantage but it's nothing nothing very
very serious not sure if it was great to
get the King up that early on that's not
not quite clear sure maybe has something
around here i don't i don't i'm not
really sure the computer likes white but
i'm not quite sure how the components to
really get something there should be two
months to go maybe i don't get the
Queen's traded that's possible I mean if
I get Queens traded have no problem at
all i'm rather better but maybe it can
maybe you can avoid it like here like
this and now I mean I could try this
kind of thing for example okay be
success 9 a-4 but it's also here white
also has this up sorry it was silly
white also has this kind of idea well it
is better for what it really seems to be
a bit better fun yeah okay well I want
that one their own time and then the
endgame okay well thanks for watching